merci monsieur le président ça tombe
bien que ce que je voulais et il m'a
dressé en tant que rapporteur sur le
lavoir retraite à monsieur le premier
ministre
on voit bien que cette affaire là c'est
tabou en france et un pacte de
génération comme l'a fort bien dit notre
président à ses voeux hier soir monsieur
le premier ministre vous y assister
quand on bouleverse un petit peu ce
pacte entre générations c'est normal
qu'ils aient un certain nombre de
réactions épidermiques
donc je voudrais savoir monsieur le
ministre quels sont les éléments dont on
va pouvoir bénéficier le sénat notamment
pour pouvoir prendre ses décisions en
pleine sérénité répondre aux questions
des français à savoir à quel âge vont
ils partir et avec quels montants de
retraite
et puis répondent aux questions que se
posent chaque sénateur quel va être le
coût de cette réforme
vous nous demandez monsieur le premier
ministre 23 habilitation à légiférer par
ordonnances quelles sont les garanties
que vous allez offrir au parlement